[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport
vorbei der Ausnahmezustand rund um
Schloss Elmau
Abschluss des g7-gipfels die Staats- und
Regierungschefs sichern der Ukraine
bedingungslose Unterstützung zu und
wollen Klimakrise und Hunger stärker
bekämpfen
Milliarden Loch bei den Krankenkassen
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach will den
Zusatzbeitrag zur gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung erhöhen
und zurück in der Bundesliga rund 1.000
Fans begrüßen wm-held Mario Götze beim
Trainingsauftakt von Eintracht Frankfurt
[Musik]
eine internationale Runde jagt die
nächste bevor der Bundeskanzler zum
NATO-Gipfel nach Madrid aufbrach zog am
Mittag auf Schloss Elmau Bilanz des
g7-treffens die Abschlusserklärung
demonstriere die große Kraft
demokratischer Bündnisse so Scholz
Umweltschutzorganisationen wie
Greenpeace sehen das anders Scholz habe
es nicht geschafft die zeitenwände für
den Klimaschutz einzuleiten Andreas
Kühnast über die gipfelergebnisse
als der britische Premier dem
amerikanischen Präsidenten seinen Kaffee
serviert hat sich die Stimmung unter den
G7 sichtbar gelockert Herren Ausflugs
Atmosphäre
dieses Ziel hat der Gipfel erreicht nach
drei Tagen acht offiziellen und
dutzenden informellen Treffen
präsentiert sich der politische Westen
so vertraut ja so freundschaftlich wie
es nur geht ein zurück in die Zeit vor
dem Krieg kann und wird es nicht geben
sagt Gastgeber Scholz das sei jedem
einzelnen der G7 klar und sein ist auch
klar
für uns liegt eine Zeit der Unsicherheit
wie es herausfordernd und darum sind
Entschlossenheit und Geschlossenheit
ebenso wichtig so fürchten die G7 das
infolge von Russlands Blockade eine der
schlimmsten Hungersnöte seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg ausbricht der Gipfel von
Ellmau stellt für die Ernährung der Welt
weitere 4,3 Milliarden Euro bereit
bekennt sich beim Klimaschutz trotz
Energiekrise zum 1,5 Grad Ziel und
beschließt der Ukraine zu helfen solange
wie nötig
die G7 wollen selensky in die beste
Position verhelfen für den Fall dass es
zu Verhandlungen kommt menschlich kommt
es sieht nicht danach aus die Runde im
Schloss erhält eine Art Antwort aus
Moskau die Forderung nach Kapitulation
kremlsprecherte mit repescov teilt heute
mit dann wäre alles binnen eines Tages
vorbei
undenkbar für die Verbündeten der
Ukraine und ihren Leitsatz Russland darf
und wird nicht gewinnen
[Musik]
so geschlossen wie lange nicht reisen
die G7 von ihrem Gipfel herab der neuen
welt-unordnung entgegen
der Bundeskanzler war erstmals Gastgeber
auf großer internationaler Bühne Theo
Koll ihre Bilanz
nun großer Gipfel Gesten sind ja nicht
die Sache des Olaf Scholz ganz im
Gegenteil lässt ja ihr leise die
Amerikaner haben deshalb auch gleich zu
Anfang den Ton und auch die Symbole
besetzt und auch täglich hier die Gipfel
Neuigkeiten verkündet aber in der Sache
haben die Deutschen Regie geführt und
das überwiegend erfolgreich es gab
einerseits die erwartbaren
unterstützungsbeschlüsse zum
ukrainekrieg beispielsweise weitere
Sanktionen gegen Russland und Milliarden
gegen die Ernährungskrise als Folge der
ausbleibenden ukrainischen
Getreideexporte andererseits aber hat
dieser Gipfel gezielt nach vorne
geschaut Scholz hatte wichtige Gäste
dazugeladen große Demokratien des Südens
die viel zu lange unzureichend beachtet
wurden und die längst vielfach
eingebunden sind den Geschäfte und
Beziehungen mit autoritären Staaten wie
Russland und China es ist nur ein erster
Schritt auf dem Weg zu einer neuen
Weltordnung aber es ist ein wichtiger
und damit dürfte auch dieser G7 Gipfel
überhaupt einer der wichtigsten gewesen
sein
Dankeschön für diese Einschätzung
telekol war das vom g7-gipfel ein
Gespräch mit dem Bundeskanzler können
Sie direkt nach uns sehen im ZDF Spezial
zum Gipfel und schon steht der nächste
an in Madrid kommen gerade die Staats-
und Regierungschefs der 30
NATO-Mitglieder zusammen das
Militärbündnis will eine neue Strategie
beschließen danach ist Russland die
bedeutendste und direkteste Bedrohung
der Schutz der Ostflanke soll oberste
Priorität bekommen im Fokus heute die
mögliche Erweiterung der NATO um
Schweden und Finnland dagegen sträubt
sich weiter die Türkei Jörg Brase
Krisentreffen in Madrid der türkische
Präsident lässt die NATO und die
Regierungen Finnlands und Schwedens
spüren dass er den Schlüssel zu deren
Mitgliedschaft in der Hand hält vor
seiner Abreise hatte Erdogan noch mal
betont er wolle Taten sehen statt
schöner Worte
wenn Schweden und Finnland nat
Mitglieder werden wollen dann müssten
sie die Sicherheitsbedenken der Türkei
die seit 70 Jahren NATO-Mitglied ist
ernst nehmen und nicht andersrum
Ismus ist ein ernsthaftes Problem nicht
nur für die Türkei meinte Finnlands
Präsident vor dem Treffen wir müssen
gemeinsam dagegen vorgehen
noch sind das für Präsident Erdogan nur
schöne Worte auf Kurden Demos in
Schweden wen fahren der verbotenen
Terrororganisation PKK
schwedensaußenministerin zeigt sich mit
Vertretern des syrischen pkk-ablegers zu
Lack sei der Umgang mit Terroristen so
die Kritik Ankaras die regierungsnahe
Zeitung höre jetzt veröffentlichte
Bilder kurdischer Terrorverdächtiger die
sich in Skandinavien aufhalten die
Türkei verlangt deren Auslieferung in
jedem Falle aber eine Verschärfung der
Anti Terrorgesetze
es geht darum dass diese Länder ihre
Politik stärken um die Strukturen der
PKK zu bekämpfen deren Einfluss deren
finanzierungs- und Rekrutierungssystem
das ist etwas das die schwedische
Regierung tun kann und tun sollte
Präsident Erdogans Widerstand zahlt sich
daheim in steigenden Umfragewerten aus
kein Grund also zurückzuweichen im
Gegenteil
Gunnar Krüger ist für uns in Madrid
dabei Gunnar treibt die Türkei die NATO
da vor sich her
zumindest bietet sich hier in Madrid
dafür die beste Gelegenheit dieser
dritte Gipfel in wenigen Tagen hat ja
wie alle anderen vor allem das Ziel
Geschlossenheit zu zeigen immer mit dem
Risiko dass dabei eben auch das
gegenteilige Bild entstehen kann und
dieses Risiko das heißt heute Erdogan er
will von Schweden und Finnland etwas was
sie ihm eigentlich nicht geben können
sie können nicht seine sein Verständnis
von Terror teilen sie können nicht ihren
Rechtsstaat über Bord werfen Schweden
geht eigentlich schon ziemlich weit
indem er sagt wir würden ein
terrorgesetz ändern wir würden
auslieferungsgesuche überprüfen wir
würden vielleicht auch ein
waffenexportverbot Aufheben aber der
Nato-Generalsekretär Jens Stoltenberg
der hier als Makler unterwegs ist der
schraubt noch mal die Erwartungen ganz
extrem runter in einer Stunde da treffen
sich hier die Staats- und
Regierungschefs zum Dinner beim
spanischen König Felipe und es wäre
schon eine faustdicke Überraschung wenn
das Thema Beitritt von Schweden und
findet sozusagen ab Moment wäre bevor
man dort auftischt Dankeschön Gunnar
Krüger nach Madrid das Comeback der NATO
wie Putins Krieg die Allianz verändert
heißt eine Dokumentation unserer
Korrespondenten seit heute in der
Mediathek zu sehen
international ist das Entsetzen groß
nach dem russischen Angriff gestern auf
die zentral-ukrainische Stadt
grimmenchuk die Zahl der Toten in dem
völlig zerstörten Einkaufszentrum stieg
auf mindestens 18 die G7 verurteilten
die Attacke als Kriegsverbrechen in den
Trümmern
letzten Moskau behauptet das eigentliche
Ziel sei ein Depot mit westlichen Waffen
gewesen Munition sei explodiert und habe
das angeblich geschlossene
Einkaufszentrum in Brand gesetzt der
ukrainische Präsident selensky sprach
dagegen von einem gezielten Angriff und
von einem Terrorakt
nach Deutschland hier hinterlassen
corona-pandemie geschiedene Pflegekosten
und Inflation ihre Spuren die
gesetzlichen Krankenkassen stecken tief
in den roten Zahlen im nächsten Jahr
fehlen mindestens 17 Milliarden Euro
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach
präsentierte heute seine Ideen wo das
Geld herkommen soll unter anderem von
Versicherten und Arbeitgebern der
Zusatzbeitrag soll um 0,3% Punkte
steigen Frank Buchwald hat Details nicht
Corona diesmal Minister Lauterbach aber
kommt wieder mit schlechten Nachrichten
die Krankenkassen sitzen auf einem
riesigen Defizit wenn man also somit mit
der Schuldenbremse und ohne
Steuererhöhungen hier klarkommen möchte
Leistungskürzungen aber ausschließt dann
sind die Herausforderungen groß die
Pandemie und großzügige
Leistungsversprechen in guten Zeiten
haben ein Loch von 17 Milliarden Euro in
die Budgets der Kassen gerissen
Lauterbach sucht deshalb nach
Geldquellen so sollen die Beiträge auf
16,2% steigen dazu hofft der Minister
auf mehr Effizienz im Gesundheitssystem
die Pharmaindustrie will er mit einer
Sonderabgabe einer Art Soli belasten
Rücklagen der Kassen sollen abschmelzen
ohne Zuschüsse aus Steuergeld aber geht
es wohl trotzdem nicht
wir sehen das jetzt nur als eine
Atempause wo wir sehen müssen ob das
2023 reicht wir sind der Meinung wir
brauchen eine mittelfristig stabile
Finanzierung der Krankenversicherung für
die Versicherten in der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung das letzte Wort ist
ohnehin noch nicht gesprochen
lauterbachsentwurf wird nun mit anderen
Ministerien abgestimmt dann geht er in
den Bundestag
zwei wichtige Termine heute in
Nordrhein-Westfalen und
Schleswig-Holstein auf dem Weg zu
schwarz-grünen Regierungen in Kiel haben
die Spitzen beider Parteien den
Koalitionsvertrag offiziell
unterzeichnet Nordrhein-Westfalen ist
schon einen Schritt weiter dort hat der
Landtag Hendrik wüst als
Ministerpräsident wiedergewählt bei der
geheimen Abstimmung kam der
CDU-Politiker auf 106 von 181 gültigen
Stimmen morgen soll dann das erste
schwarz-grüne Kabinett in NRW vereidigt
werden
die EU-Umweltminister wollen heute über
eine Revolution in der Autoindustrie
entscheiden ob Neuwagen mit
verbrennermotoren ab 2035 verboten
werden die deutsche Position lautet im
Prinzip ja aber denn Autos mit
synthetischen Kraftstoffen sogenannte
e-fuels sollen erlaubt bleiben
vorausgegangen war ein heftiger
Koalitionsstreit weil die Grünen diese
Ausnahme nicht wollten aus Brüssel in
Arbeit ist
ab 2035 soll nur noch mit Stecker
getankt werden keine Benziner keine
Dieselautos mehr ob dieser Plan der
EU-Kommission die Zustimmung aller
EU-Länder findet ist noch offen
Deutschland will ja sagen aber auch
Ausnahmen wir vertreten die gemeinsame
Linie der Regierung die auf der einen
Seite eine starke CO2-Reduktion für den
Verkehrsbereich unterstützen möchte und
auf der anderen Seite
technologieoffenheit gewährleisten will
technologieoffenheit das heißt dass doch
nach 2035 noch verbrennermotoren erlaubt
wären wenn sie künstliche Kraftstoffe
sogenannte e-fuels tanken eine
fdp-bedingung die Technologie der
e-fuels ist längst nicht ausgereift wir
wollen Klimaneutralität technologieoffen
erreichen und nicht zu einem frühen
Zeitpunkt Technologien ausschließen
deren Bedeutung man in Zukunft heute
noch nicht abschließend beurteilen kann
über diese fdp-wünsche hatte es Streit
vergeben mit den Grünen in der Berliner
Ampel jetzt müssen die Entwürfe in
Luxemburg überarbeitet werden auch
andere Länder wollen Änderungen
jetzt nicht entscheiden das ist doch
jetzt noch Illusion
2035 kann Polen nicht akzeptieren doch
die Klimakrise drängt und die Industrie
braucht Planungssicherheit die
Verhandlungen hier in Luxemburg ziehen
sich wohl bis in die Nacht
Josef S ist 101 Jahre alt drei davon hat
er nach Überzeugung des
landgerichtsneuruppin im KZ
Sachsenhausen verbracht als Wachmann bis
1945 wegen Beihilfe zum Mord an
tausenden Häftlingen ist das damalige
ss-mitglied jetzt zu fünf Jahren Haft
verurteilt worden er sei willfähriger
Helfer der Täter gewesen so das Gericht
er selbst bestreitet die Taten über das
Urteil Kathrin Lindner
Josef s heute morgen im Gerichtssaal er
hat bis zuletzt bestritten im KZ
Sachsenhausen Bachmann gewesen zu sein
doch das Urteil lautet fünf Jahre Haft
wegen Beihilfe zum Mord an tausenden von
heftlingen das Gericht war nach der
Beweisaufnahme nach dieser langen
Beweisaufnahme davon überzeugt dass er
fast drei Jahre lang als Wachmann im
Konzentrationslager Sachsenhausen tätig
war durch seine Tätigkeit die dort
verübten Morde unterstützt hat die
Wachtürme stehen noch in Sachsenhausen
zehntausende Häftlinge wurden ermordet
oder starben an den lebensfeindlichen
Bedingungen als ss-wachmann war Josef s
wilfähiger Helfer der
Vernichtungsmaschine die ohne Menschen
wie ihn nicht funktioniert hätte so die
Richter
das Urteil sendet eine Botschaft wer
solche Verbrechen begeht kann auch 80
Jahre später zur Verantwortung gezogen
werden diese Verfahren sind wichtig im
Kampf gegen die Verleugnung des
Holocaust der 98-Jährige Alfons
stutinski überlebte das KZ Sachsenhausen
gequert und bewacht von tausenden von SS
Männern er hätte sich gewünscht dass
viel mehr von ihnen zur Verantwortung
gezogen worden wären mit dem heutigen
Tag kommt man auf 69
das bisschen zu spät
was der richtige Verbrecher die leben
heute schon nicht mehr nicht wenn man es
ist ja alle nimmt unschuldig ist da
keine Idee die Verteidigung hat Revision
angekündigt doch das Gericht hat heute
klargemacht Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit verjähren nicht
die Zahl der antisemitischen Vorfälle in
Deutschland ist im vergangenen Jahr
weiter angestiegen das berichtet der
zuständige Bundesverband in seinem
Jahresbericht und listet insgesamt
2738 Fälle auf das sind im Schnitt mehr
als sieben pro Tag gegenüber dem Vorjahr
bedeutet dies einen Anstieg um 40
Prozent allerdings hat auch die Zahl der
Meldestellen zugenommen trotzdem gehen
Experten auch weiterhin von einer hohen
Dunkelziffer aus
im US-Bundesstaat Texas sind 50 Menschen
offenbar bei dem Versuch gestorben
illegal in die USA einzureisen der
Feuerwehrchef der Großstadt San Antonio
bestätigte zunächst den Fund von 46
Leichen im völlig überhitzten Laderaum
eines abgestellten Lastwagens 16
Überlebende wurden in Kliniken gebracht
vier von ihnen konnten aber nicht mehr
gerettet werden die Polizei geht von
einem schleuserversuch aus Mexiko aus
drei Verdächtige wurden festgenommen
und jetzt ein ganz harter Schnitt zum
Sport Norbert mit dem
rasentennisklassiker in wimbletten
bei den Frauen hat es die Wimbledon
Siegerin von 2018 Angelique Kerber in
die zweite Runde geschafft Andrea
Petkovic dagegen ist schon ausgeschieden
viermal gibt Petkovic den eigenen
Aufschlag ab leistet sich zu viele
einfache Fehler nach einer Stunde und 18
Minuten ist Wimbledon 2022 für die
Darmstädterin beendet 4:6 und 3:6 gegen
die Schweizerin Victoria gulovic
Angelique Kerber ist in ihrem erstrunden
Match gegen die Französin Christina
amladenovic nur im zweiten Satz kurz
gefordert den ersten gewinnt sie mit 6:0
im zweiten heißt es am Ende sieben zu
fünf am Mittwoch spielt Kerber gegen die
Polin Magda lined
am 6 juli startet die Frauenfußball EM
in England das deutsche Team das
bereitet sich in Herzogenaurach vor
Bundestrainerin Martina Forst
Tecklenburg blickt dem Turnier gelassen
und voller Vorfreude entgegen
wir sind die letzten Tage der
Vorbereitung auf die EM die härteste
Trainingsphase ist vorbei in 10 Tagen
beginnt für Deutschland das Turnier mit
dem Spiel gegen Dänemark wir haben noch
nicht alle bei 100%. aber das wussten
wir vorher haben wir noch ein paar Tage
Zeit bis zum ersten Spiel bzw haben wir
auch mehr vor als nur drei Spiele zu
machen die wichtigste Nachricht
Alexandra Popp ist nach ihrer
corona-erkrankung zurück erzielte auch
das letzte Tor zum 7 zu 0 beim Test
gegen die Schweiz klar muss man auch
sagen dass glaube ich die Schweiz nicht
in einem besten Zustand war und wir das
schon noch ein bisschen relativieren
müssen das ganze aber das ist uns allen
definitiv bewusst dass es gegen stärkere
Mannschaften ja nicht so einfach geht am
Sonntag geht es dann nach England mit
dem Flieger
der finaltorschütze bei der Fußball-WM
von 2014 Mario Götze ist zurück in
Deutschland heute erster Trainingstag
des 30-jährigen als neuer
Offensivspieler bei Eintracht Frankfurt
bejubelt von zahlreichen Fans Götze
kommt für rund 3 Millionen Euro von PSV
Eindhoven zur Eintrag und hat dort einen
Dreijahresvertrag
finden die Frankfurter gut nämlich
Gewitter bleiben uns erhalten wo genau
erfahren Sie gleich von ostentelli
Marietta Slomka begrüßte ihm heute
journal um kurz vor 10 Uhr darin ein
Interview mit dem britischen Premier
Boris Johnson wir danken für Ihr
Interesse und wünschen Ihnen noch einen
schönen Abend bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter in den nächsten
Stunden müssen wir mit weiteren
Gewittern rechnen es liegt an diesem
Tief was über die Alpen zu uns kommt und
in der Nacht und morgen im Tagesverlauf
weitere Gewitter dann bringen wird in
der Nacht also aus den Alpen heraus
schaue und Gewitter die nach Norden
wachsen und auch Richtung Erzgebirge
wird es danach ganz im Westen ist es
trocken bei tiefsten Temperaturen von 17
Grad im Südosten und 9 Grad im
hessischen Bergland ja und morgen im
Tagesverlauf teilweise kräftige Gewitter
im unwetterbereich von den Alpen über
das Erzgebirge bis Richtung Berlin hier
immer wieder Schauer sonst aber trocken
teils sonniger Abschnitte bei höchsten
Temperaturen bis 29 Grad im Westen
Deutschlands und zum Beispiel 22 Grad an
den Alpen die nächsten Tage am
Donnerstag einzelne schauen und Gewitter
bis 31 Grad Freitag weitere Gewitter und
Samstag trocken und damit ein schönen
Abend